in the u.s. most kids go to school based
on where they live that means when
families decide where to live one big
factor is how good is the school in the
neighborhood so how do you figure that
out well you could visit the school see
how the playground looks or ask friends
about it but all of these seem so
imprecise plus it's kind of weird to
visit dozens of playgrounds so these
days you would probably Google the
school and you'll almost certainly end
up on this website grade schools org
grade schools is a nonprofit school
ratings website they provide a number
rating for almost every public school in
America the worst schools are a 1 and
the best schools are a 10 there are
other websites and organizations that
rate schools but great schools is the
big one it's become America's unofficial
school rating system but what exactly
are these scores measuring well we dug
into the data to find out and what we
found is that this score often ends up
showing something other than how good a
school is
great schools started in the late 1990s
they visited schools around the San
Francisco Bay Area and talk to each
school's principal but that method of
profiling schools wasn't exactly
scalable they couldn't go visit every
single school in the country that would
be prohibitively expensive it was hard
enough as it was and that Barnum is a
reporter at chalk beat a site that
covers education he helped us report
this story going to every single school
was just not a sustainable model then in
2001 something huge happened for great
schools Congress passed a national
education law called No Child Left
Behind No Child Left Behind required
schools to give state standardized tests
each year in grades three through eight
to figure out how many of them met a
standard called proficiency proficiency
is basically each u.s. state standard
for what kitchen though at a certain
grade level so that gave them a lot of
data to rate schools all across the
country after No Child Left Behind great
schools have the numbers they can base
their scores on today they say this
proficiency score is the biggest factor
in the ratings that gives each
elementary middle school accounting for
about half the score but when we start
looking at grade schools data we notice
something here are basically all the
public elementary middle schools in
Denver and a few of its suburbs with the
help of journalists at choc beat we
sorted them by the percentage of
low-income students in each school these
schools have more low-income students
and these schools have fewer now let's
highlight the schools that got a great
schools rating of at least a 7 which is
what they consider above average you can
see that almost all of these better
rated schools are more affluent and this
is true in basically every city from San
Francisco to Detroit
and this correlation also appears when
we sort these schools by racial
demographics
here's Denver again the schools on the
Left have more black and Hispanic
students and the schools on the right
have fewer so which schools got a rating
of 7 or above it schools with more white
and Asian kids who tend to come from
more affluent neighborhoods grade
schools ratings seem to confirm
something that many people already
assume that whiter and richer schools
are simply better here's the problem
that's not necessarily true and to
understand why we need to look at one of
the big issues with measuring
proficiency America's neighborhoods are
highly unequal and when children show up
to school in affluent neighborhoods that
are mostly white and Asian they're
better prepared for school than children
in poor mostly black and Hispanic areas
so when we look at proficiency were
actually often measuring how prepared
these kids were coming in not what
happens inside the school so if
proficiency is more about measuring the
student in the school how could we
actually measure the school's
performance
well another common way of measuring
schools is to see how much the school
helps a student improve this is called a
growth score now growth is still just
based on test scores which not everyone
is a fan of but it's how many schools
prefer we measure them the principal's I
talked to felt that it was more fair to
judge them on growth if you're a school
that is serving a lot of students who
are coming in at a low level you could
be doing a great job with those students
but it might not be showing up in
proficiencies not all states report grow
scores which is a problem in itself but
most do and grow scores show that there
are many low income schools that are
pretty good here's every Denver school
again and again sorted by the percentage
of low-income students and now if we
highlight the schools that have an above
average growth score which is data we
got from great schools own website we
can see that there are lots of schools
and poor neighborhoods that are very
good at educating their students and
this is true in other cities too like
Indianapolis
and Detroit but in the grade schools
rating system growth only matters about
half as much as proficiency does which
is why these schools are rarely rated
highly even if they do a great job
teaching students we talked to great
schools they said the important thing is
that they give parents a broader picture
of school quality and that their site
helps underserved families make good
choices they also stressed that they've
actually changed the rating system to
start considering growth alongside
proficiency and the data reflects this
but there's still this really stark
correlation with race and class of
students but it is lower than what it
was before that's not entirely their
fault not every state reports growth
scores but even where growth scores are
available grade school still weights
proficiency a lot more and that models
the difference between two definitions
of good schools the ones that do the
best job teaching students and the ones
that get kids who are already high
achieving who tend to be from white and
affluent families so maybe the real
question is which one do parents
actually want
[Music]